[Musik]
die
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sail
israel heute gibt es einen richtig
leckeren stollen und frau habe einen
spekulanten stollen gebacken und ich
dachte mir das ist wirklich an der zeit
letzte tag gab es nämlich nur so ganz
kleines christstollen konfekt was
natürlich auch sehr lecker ist und vor
allem sehr handlich aber dieses jahr
dachte ich mir jetzt noch mal richtig
schön großem stolz
von außen sieht man es natürlich nicht
viel aber innen ist gefüllt mit marokko
marzipan masse mit bisschen spekulatius
gehört also richtig schön winterlich und
was ich besonders gut finde ohne
getrocknete früchte denn ich weiß viele
mögen die gar nicht so gerne
aber falls man natürlich welche rein
machen möchte geht es natürlich auch ich
zeige euch mal die zutaten lasst euch
nicht davon abschrecken es sieht nach
ziemlich viel aus aber sind viele
grundzutaten die man eigentlich zu hause
hat also los geht mir nicht so taten die
vorne habe ich die zutaten für den
stollen ich habe 500 gramm mehl und
päckchen backpulver 90 gramm zucker
einen halben teelöffel wann een extrakt
zwei teelöffel spekulatius und eine
prise salz 125 g weiche butter 250 km
eine unbehandelte zitrone und zweier
hier sind die zutaten für die
schokofüllung und zwar ein esslöffel
milch 20 gramm pro 100 gramm ac fan
rohmasse und 100 gramm gehackte mandeln
und hier zwei esslöffel milch zum
bestreichen und für später dann noch
jeweils 50 gramm weißen und braunen
zucker und 100 gramm flüssige butter
ich gebe zu es sieht nach ziemlich viel
aus aber was im prinzip eigentlich nur
grundzutaten ich werde zuerst einmal den
stollen teig zubereiten und gibt dafür
das mehl in eine rührschüssel wir
könnten jetzt mit der hand oder mit der
küchenmaschine zubereitet oder mit einem
handrührgerät zb da kommt jetzt
backpulver mit dazu
als die trockenen zutaten salz und
spekulatius gewürz das spekulations
gewiss könnten von selbst zusammen
menschen aber wenn ihr jetzt nicht so
viele einzelne gewürze zu hause habe ich
jetzt auch allein sind aber dann könnt
ihr einfach auf das spekulations
zurückgreifen ein bisschen einfacher
total wie früher ich kotzen
geht jetzt noch vinyl aids tag dazu
darf natürlich auch hier nicht fehlen
und dann kommen auch gleich die butter
quark die eier und die zitronenschale
das und die butter die sollte jetzt
zimmerwand sein
und weil ich meine auch nicht aus dem
kühlschrank geholt hatte habe ich sie
alle waren fein geraspelt also fein
gerieben und dann einfach kurz auf die
warme halb platte oder im ofen gestellt
und dann habt ihr leben gleicht finden
[Musik]
und die zutaten werden jetzt miteinander
verkettet
[Musik]
der teig ist auch wirklich super schnell
hergestellt und den nehme ich jetzt
heraus und werde ein drittel davon ist
abschneiden und dieses eine drittel
kommt jetzt wieder zurück in die
maschine
denn da könnte ich jetzt noch die
anderen zutaten rein also marzipan
das habe ich vorher schon ein bisschen
fein gerastert damit sie es gut
verbindet die gehackten sünde und ich
führe jetzt hier noch kakao und milch
[Musik]
zum kakaopulver einfach so viel milch
dazugeben
dass das so ein bisschen feucht ist und
den teig eben nicht austrocknet dann
entsteht so eine kleine passte und die
kommt jetzt hier auch mit rein und dann
für knete ich nochmal die zutaten
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich erst mal den hellen teig
und den rolle ich jetzt hier auf einer
leicht bemehlten arbeitsfläche zu einem
großen rechteck aus
[Musik]
den hellen tag lege ich jetzt kurz weg
also das rechteck und nehmen den dunklen
der schützen bisschen weicher da brauche
ich jetzt ein bisschen mehr mit zum
auswahl
und diesen teigrolle ich jetzt genauso
groß aus
[Musik]
den hell und tag bestreitet hilft mit
der mint dient oder die sorgte dass der
dunkle zeitgleich daran klebt fröhlich
den dunklen auf den außen stab aus
überschüssiges nähen kann weg und kannst
du darüber lägen über den teig knapp
verfehlt aber das ist es nicht schlimm
denn jetzt wird sowieso eine seite
eingerollt daher passt hier ganz gutes
karma obsolet rücken und 10
eine seite rolle ich jetzt nur bis zu
einem drittel auf also bisher ungefähr
und die zweite rolle auch bis dahin auf
die könnte jetzt gern so ein bisschen
hier darüber legen und den stollen schön
vor
die enden die verknotung ein bisschen
druck sie zusammen
[Musik]
und hier in die mitte
also fort den stollen einfach so dass er
euch gut gefällt und dann fliegt den
stollen mit auerbach folie auf mein
perfektes backblech und kann ihn
erzielen mit einem drittel der flüssigen
butter bestreichen und ist ganz wichtig
dadurch bekommen eine tolle farbe und
wird natürlich auch super saftig und die
restlichen zwei drittel werde ich dann
später während dem und nach dem backen
drauf streich
[Musik]
habe ich hier den braunen und weißen
zucker vermischt und wer jetzt ein
drittel davon auf den stollen streuen
[Musik]
insgesamt wird der stollen jetzt bei 170
grad ober unterhitze etwa 45 minuten
gebacken und nach 30 minuten werde ich
ihnen noch mal mit einem drittel butter
bestreichen und mit einem drittel zucker
bestreuen und dann darf er eben noch mal
15 minuten weiter backen
[Musik]
jetzt ist der stollen fett gebackene
stäbchen probe mit zahnstocher grad
und jetzt werde ich ihnen noch ganz heiß
erneut mit der butter bestreichen und
mit dem zucker bestreuen und dann erst
mal komplett abkühlen lassen
ich denke jetzt vielleicht dass er zu
süß wird und zu mächtig aber stollen
es müssen ja saftig sein die lassen sich
auch lange lagern deswegen bestreichen
sie eben auch mit der butter und da sind
bleiben sie schön saftig und ich habe im
teig gar nicht so viel zucker
deswegen ist der zucker aus london ohne
zu viel
[Musik]
jetzt ist der stollen scheint abgekühlt
und ich habe hier noch mit etwas süßem
schnee bestreut
ich finde es sieht einfach immer schön
winterlich aus jetzt kann ich ihn
anschneiden und ich würde sagen der
junge mann hinter der kamera kommt nach
vorne alle freuen uns jetzt murat komm
-rat kund und es kommt freut sich aber
noch mehr den markt kennen das ist der
mag unser freund und da mag ich heute
hier hat uns besucht da war trat in der
nähe
dann habe ich sagt haak muss natürlich
gerne mit fotokamera und hunger hunger
herrscht ja selber gekocht selber
gemacht natürlich so so sieht der stolz
von innen aus wie gemalt oder das jedoch
kleiner aus richtig schön also
normalerweise lässt man stollen jetzt
eigentlich noch eingepackt bestimmt so
ein paar tage stehen damit einfach noch
mal richtig durchziehen kann die aromen
können sich entfalten
aber so viel zeit haben jetzt natürlich
gar nicht gerne und stelle
wahrscheinlich sofort probieren es
gedacht das jetzt hier heute noch mit
mir vor der kamera stehe ich nicht aber
schon mal gut und wenn es den zuschauern
gefällt dann kommt einfach vorbei
ich würde sagen wenn es den zuschauern
nicht gefällt ich komme weil er gut ist
richtig richtig schlecht ich schätze sie
gar nicht schön saftig lecker was ihr
vielleicht wissen solltet ich habe ihn
vorher natürlich darauf hingewiesen dass
regel nummer eins bei uns ist egal ob es
schmeckt oder nicht schmeckt man muss im
rhein ist schmeckt gar nicht gehört
ein schmeckt tatsächlich also ich rede
auch gesagt wenn es nicht schön würde so
bin ich
man steht dass das selten vor der kamera
möchte noch jemanden grüßen
darf ich meine mama kunststoff sonst nie
meine mama krise hallo liebe mama auch
bekannt als oma traudl ich grüße dich
hallo oma traudl schmeckt gut
sofort dann schneide mir dass jetzt
gleich noch eine scheibe ablassen
kaffeehaus oder vielleicht nochmal und
kinderpunsch und falls ihr das rezept
nach lesen wollt dann geht ihr auf sell
ist klagt der etat stets noch mal ganz
genau für euch und ich wünsche euch ganz
viel spaß beim nachbacken bis zum
nächsten mal
ich finde das nächste mal könnte
eigentlich mal miesbach schmidt kohl und
dann wissen wir den märkten
ihr habt ihr monat hat vorhin schon
geschlagen ja das stimmt das reicht
eigentlich immer wenn ich komme wachstum
das mit der post vorhin hat er kommt von
und klingeln wenn ich rein gelassen sagt
ein junger mann zu mir acht kannst du
noch mal runter gehen da hat der mann ja
der post gehe ich wieder runter man sagt
einfach von der brust zu mir sind sie
den händlern
da sage ich nein herr ich alles klein
und hässlich beschrieben
herzhaft gelacht
der mann hat auch gelacht als der murat
weiß er weiter und wir uns wehren
gesehen hat auf den messen ist ja immer
sehr hart und meerrettich werden viel
spaß also der magische ab und zu mit uns
auf messe er macht damit uns das ganze
silicone werkzeug und deswegen wir
kennen uns schon sehr lange und lieben
uns an com ist gemein becken alsbald
[Musik]